the campaign for a second brexit
referendum appears to have stalled in
recent days MP's dropped their proposal
for a cross-table amendment calling for
people's vote last week because they
said it was unlikely to pass without
formal support for labour so where do
those who want another referendum go
from here to discuss that I'm joined by
here Lee Dixon who is the Deputy Chair
of the people's vote campaign and by dr.
Phillip Lee MP former Conservative
justice minister who is now chair of the
right to vote campaign welcome to you
both morning
this is campaign dead now if you can't
even get a referendum when Parliament's
having this great debate on the agenda I
don't think so at all I mean you've got
to see we've actually come a hell of a
long way first of all there was that
massive defeat of the government steel a
miserable deal then there was labour
trying to get a general election it
failed now we're having these important
votes tomorrow in Parliament and I think
it's only natural that Parliament should
explore all the other alternatives
before pushing the matter to the king
their gender in this is 60 days to go
yes I'm not saying that there should be
a long delay but but I think what's
important is that Parliament is in the
process of trying to figure out whether
there is a viable form of brexit which
is good now I don't think that there is
any viable form of brexit that's good
there are viable forms of brexit which
are bad and there are fantasy forms of
brexit which are good but it's only
reasonable that the Labour Party tries
to figure out whether there is such a
thing I think they will fail it's also
only reasonable that some conservatives
who want these Norway style options
should also figure out whether there's
an alternative that works but when they
find out as I think they will that there
is no good alternative brexit that will
be the time to say ask the people what
do you say yeah I mean you've just
launched your organizer I mean I think
first of all Westminster process story
is sort of we're going to put an
amendment oh no you're not when in fact
actually all four doctors had never
agreed to place the amendments the facts
the matter secondly the referendum is
sort of finest a referendum
is against the general election in my
mind when when Parliament faces the
reality that no form of brexit will pass
the house there's no agreement we have a
choice we have a referendum we have a
general election that vote I'd like to
see on the floor of the house I'd like
to see whether the second referendum
will but the truth is there is in the
votes there too no but there never was
you only ever win a vote in the floor of
the house you know the backing of either
the opposition or the government and at
the moment the only two people that
matter in this a Theresa May and Jeremy
Corbyn seemingly and neither of them
have shown a desire to have a second
referendum so there's no point in
actually having a vote when you know the
answer but why not from your point of
view I mean you think brexit is a bad
idea like no no no no you know I correct
you my position has always been that I
voted I supported remain my point is is
the bricks that we're going to get it
doesn't match the promises of 2016 so
it's it's invalid the mandate doesn't
carry as far as I'm concerned so we need
informed consent from the public to the
bricks to the efforts to actually a
referendum is just a way of reversing I
don't think that's true Adam I mean I am
I'm again as Philip I'm I'm transparent
that I voted to stem also transparent
that I would like to stop brexit but
that doesn't mean to say it's a way of
invalidating what happened in do you
have a single breaks a tear working for
your organization um no I don't but I
mean what but that doesn't mean that but
but that doesn't mean that I'm trying to
invalidate 2016 I think that what
happened is three years have happened a
lot of new facts are on the table that
we weren't aware of remains the majority
who voted for I don't know I think that
it's a huge fact that we got two weeks
ago which is that there was a 230 vote
majority historic vote against the deal
the very important point about the 2016
referendum is that it was a real form of
staying in the EU versus the fantasy of
brexit I think what's happened is that
now we're looking at the reality it's
only right that the people should have a
chance to say whether they want that
reality or not I think the interesting
question is going to be to ask members
of the ERG who passionately believe in a
particular form of brexit whether they
would rather back a brick
that falls far short of that or whether
they would rather take their breaks it
back to the sample well what about you
eventually in the end are you gonna vote
for this deal
no I I'm never going to vote for a deal
that materializes some part is why I
resigned
what I want to vote for is a deal is
subject to a public mandate because
there is no way the campaign in 2016
Matt is the bricks that the people are
going to get and I don't think that is
right since for however much they try to
tweak it fundamentally the principle
stays stays the same we need to inform
consent to the public before we proceed
with this Brixham if you both want a
referendum why aren't you working
together well I mean I can I can I
answer that also that false allegation
made in that that new there the article
the people's were aware of the right of
a campaign being formed from the answer
from the app from the outset so we are
working in tandem to try to secure that
final say referendum and that has always
been the case and I can say that theirs
as well as being the Deputy Chair of the
people so it I am the chair of in facts
which is a journalistic website and when
Phillip launched right to vote we wrote
a very nice article on in fact saying
Bravo to them it's important to have a
strong conservative voice in this debate
so you have had a bit of a squabble
haven't you within the whole movement I
mean it was people like you leaning on
people like him that stopped an
amendment no no that's totally untrue
absolutely and the doctors made their
decision in isolation of everybody else
yes there are people who worry about
putting a vote that might not win
fundamentally the point is that until a
front bench pivots towards the people it
isn't going to happen and the doctors
recognize that as much as anybody else I
think the question that has to be asked
of both to reason May and of Jeremy
Corbyn that if they're not prepared to
do a second referendum are they saying
that no deal is acceptable because I
don't think they are I do now I just
think this point about No Deal
it's really important because this week
and tomorrow the focus is on stopping No
Deal and I think there is a huge
majority in parliament against no deal
we have the Queen
last week saying state compromises were
seen see said
seek out common ground now if you wanted
to seek out common ground the government
would allow a free vote tomorrow on
these No Deal amendments and you would
find that there was a huge majority
against crashing out we also know we
also know against that from opinion
surveys that of the options No Deal is
actually the most popular now with the
public we also know that those opinion
surveys a certain proportion people
responding for No Deal men staying in
the European Union yeah okay so trying
to interpret softly how many were a poll
where where some people who
misunderstood the question I don't think
it's necessary but that's the whole
point
misunderstanding the question that's
what you keep on saying people
misunderstood the question but what
Holloman took a decision to have a
referendum and people voted in the way
they do they did and the government is
right to be honoring the 2016 results
and bringing forward the Prix it was
deliverable the reality is that any form
of brexit Norway Canada all requires a
withdrawal agreement withdrawal
agreement terms are what they are
the Prime Minister is on the very best
in these through these circumstances but
that wasn't on the side of the bus so
and that's my point what's the route to
getting they referendum you've been
campaigning for well I think it is
really important to make clear that
Parliament is against crashing out with
no deal so I think that is a really that
is the most important next milestone I
personally would like not only those
amendments tomorrow but I think there
should be a full and frank debate in
Parliament on No Deal we've not had that
amazingly we've had two and a half years
and we haven't had a proper debate we've
had bits and bobs of that I think once
that's happened I think then Jeremy
Corbyn needs to put forward his proposal
and see if Parliament likes it I think
that you've unfortunately it's another
fantasy because it's a bit like the
customs union a bit like a single mile
agreement and then the only way and then
I think at that point I think Jeremy
Corbyn will conclude that with a heavy
heart he has to back a people's vote and
I think also at that point many of the
Conservatives who are backing this
Norway plan will do so as well and we
will then have the majority that we need
okay thank you very much eat